[Música]
para qué sirven los mocos
de vive en los jabones
quien mató a los dinosaurios quién
hola cuando crezca se va a convertir en
humana la lola es nuestra perra
hoy mañana pero como todos los días es
hoy
es casarse es como cuando cazan animales
para comérselos
en el futuro
estas preguntas me las hicieron mi hijo
de tres años mi hija de cinco
sobrinos
infancias con las que trabajé en las
investigaciones psicosociales en las que
participé
también me preguntaron cosas más
difíciles de responder
porque le mataron a esa mujer
quien esté well y por qué no aparece
porque hay personas ricas y personas
pobres
las infancias son así
incomodan con sus preguntas
a lo largo de mi carrera pude generar
una serie de conocimientos con relación
a las infancias que me interpelaron
profundamente
esa interpelación incluso entró en
crisis cuando me convertí en mamá y tuve
que vérmelas con las infancias todos los
días de mi vida y ahí terminé a
ratificar que incomodan
incomodan desde que llegan y se suman a
una rutina que claramente no estaba
pensada para ellos y no les organizan
horas de sueño rutinas la casa
y les cuento como incomodan cuando
empiezan a hablar porque nos hacen pasar
una vergüenza bárbara porque les decimos
que no mientan excepto cuando tiene que
ver con nosotros y nos ponen frente a
nuestra propia contradicción
o porque se toman las cosas literal o
son brutalmente honestos como mi sobrina
que me dijo que me quería mucho aunque
yo le regalara juguetes de mala calidad
pero lo más interesante es que incomodan
cuando empiezan a tratar de entender el
mundo
la comprensión del mundo social es una
tarea cognitiva bastante compleja
los adultos mediatizados ese
conocimiento con interpretaciones y
ellos van construyendo sus propias
teorías y ahí
comienzan a hacer preguntas ingenuas
incisivas
desestabilizadoras preguntas difíciles
de esas que no quisiéramos tener que
responder
porque los ricos no comparten su plata
con los más pobres
los jueces son siempre justos
porque existen juguetes de nenes y
juguetes de nenas
todos tenemos que hacerle caso al
presidente
yo me sentía rara cada vez que un niño o
una niña me hacía una de estas preguntas
pero no lo pude poner en palabras hasta
que martín a ezkurra en un conversatorio
que lo invite lo dijo con total claridad
las infancias se mueven con una
pedagogía de la incomodidad
él dijo que hay una pedagogía una
capacidad de enseñarnos algo con las
preguntas que generan y le agradece a su
hijo por todo lo que felizmente lo había
incomodado en su vida
me quedé pensando que nos queda de las
preguntas y las incomodidades que nos
generan las infancias
me acordé cuan incómoda me sentí cuando
me enteré que mi sobrina a quien yo le
había regalado una muñeca negra jugaba
feliz con su muñeca dentro de su casa
pero cuando salía al mundo exterior le
escondía
porque le daba vergüenza
porque percibía el rechazo la
discriminación el prejuicio
y como con ese acto nos incomodaba a su
mamá ya mi queremos las representantes
de ese mundo adulto racista que ella
comenzaba a decodificar
a lo largo de nuestras investigaciones
pudimos comprobar con los adultos nos
movemos con una matriz de pensamiento
adultocéntrica
y que gran parte de las respuestas que
damos a las preguntas incómodas de las
infancias proviene desde allí desde esta
certeza de que el mundo debiera
organizarse según las normas adultas
según nuestras formas de pensar y de
sentir
desde esta postura el saber y el poder
están puestos del lado adulto nosotros
sabemos los niños no
son muy chiquitos no van a entender no
preguntes esas cosas son de grandes
estamos hablando los grandes no te metas
desde esa perspectiva los niños no son
ciudadanos no pueden opinar no pueden
participar los niños son el futuro no el
presente
frecuentemente desde esta mirada se
obturan las preguntas de las infancias
se acalla la incomodidad no se los
escucha me acuerdo una vez en una cena
con familias y amigos mi hija me mire me
dice mamá yo también quiero hablar
yo le dije bueno habla hija
y ella me respondió pero es que nadie me
mira
y es así
no los miramos no le sostenemos la
mirada y cuando lo hacemos le damos
respuestas encorsetadas que reproducen
las formas en las cuales ya funciona el
mundo sin tomar esta pregunta como una
oportunidad para mirar críticamente ese
mundo
entonces si nuestra hija nos pregunta
por qué el compañerito le pega en el
jardín les decimos que es porque gusta
de ella y no sabe cómo demostrárselo y
ahí reproducimos la legitimación de las
violencias de género
o si nos pregunta por qué hay personas
pobres les decimos que porque no se
esforzaron lo suficiente y seguimos
legitimando el mito de la meritocracia
yo creo que ellos se dan cuenta de la
pobreza de nuestras respuestas nuestras
respuestas son precarias y lógicas
insuficientes
contradictorias y ellos se dan cuenta
ellos todavía miran con cierta capacidad
de asombro el mundo en el que les tocó
nacer los adultos solemos perder la
capacidad de asombro
pero ellos miran este mundo detonado y
se asombran y no entienden
y es que es inentendible
un mundo que da señales de agotamiento
una forma de organizar la vida que
derrocha muerte un mundo plagado de
desigualdades e incoherencias con
sequías con inundaciones con cambio
climático con personas que se van al
espacio y otras que no tienen acceso a
agua potable en gran parte del mundo
y las infancias ven y preguntan y
nosotros no estamos a la altura de sus
preguntas
mi hija le pregunto a su tía si ella
sabía que para comer carne había que
matar animales
cuando su tía le dijo que si
ella perpleja le pregunto y por qué
seguir comiendo animales
nos incomodan con esas preguntas y
nosotros no queremos aprender con ellas
ellos subrayan lo absurdo de nuestras
respuestas lo insuficiente de nuestros
intentos
en nuestras investigaciones
pudimos trabajar con ciertas
experiencias que se posicionan desde
otro paradigma desde uno que les
reconoce su lugar como sujetos sociales
en tiempo presente y que valora su
aporte en la construcción de otro mundo
posible por ejemplo algunas
instituciones escolares generan
dispositivos que tienen a veces un
efecto un poco paradojal
algunas escuelas proponen simulacros de
participación entonces hacemos como si
organizaremos una asamblea como si
realizáramos una elección incluso
algunas escuelas les proponen escribir
una carta al presidente o presidenta con
sus ideas y sus propuestas
el tema es que estos dispositivos no
buscan otorgarles un lugar genuino de
reconocimiento y de participación
supuestamente buscan transmitir
competencias ciudadanas pero para ser
utilizadas en un futuro porque en el
presente lo que generan es una fuerte
desilusión cuando la acción no genera
frutos porque hicimos una elección en la
que no elegimos a nadie
escribimos una carta que nunca fue
mandada y que jamás fue respondida
esto cambia sustantivamente cuando nos
posicionamos desde otro lugar
en una de las organizaciones
territoriales con las que trabaje se les
propuso a los chicos y las chicas que
con ocasión del 24 de marzo escribieran
una carta a la organización madre de
plaza de mayo con sus ideas y sus
reflexiones sobre el golpe de estado
la carta se mandó y las madres le
respondieron
esa fue una experiencia sumamente
significativa para ellos
así pudimos evaluar como s otros
dispositivos de educación ciudadana que
trabajando desde esta mirada lograron
impactar de manera positiva en el
desarrollo infantil
colaborar en el desarrollo del
pensamiento crítico en la adquisición de
nociones sociales y políticas complejas
y también en la adquisición de
herramientas para la participación
social y política efectiva
también en lo cotidiano podemos cambiar
el 'chip' y posicionarnos desde otro
lugar
escucha germina mente las preguntas que
te hagan las infancias que forman parte
de tu vida para
reflexionar antes de responderles
automáticamente
preguntarles qué opinan cómo lo ven
debatir pensa con ellos
si sos docente
habilitar es un lugar en la dinámica
escolar que puedan realmente impactar en
la escuela de la que forman parte
si sos mamá o papá
bancar la rebeldía el cuestionamiento
incluso a tu propia autoridad y
ayudarles a involucrarse en las cosas
que pasan en el mundo sobre todo en
aquellas que les generan interés y que
les afectan
y mira si alguna de todas las preguntas
que hicimos hoy acá te incómodo aunque
sea un poquito vamos bien
volvés sobre ellas revisa esta
incomodidad y prepárate para la próxima
vez que una infancia te interpele
estoy convencida de que sostener la
incomodidad bancarla nos hace revisar
las respuestas nos saca de la zona de
confort y nos pone en movimiento
y que caminar junto con ellos y no
delante de ellos nos encamina hacia el
horizonte de construcción social que
necesitamos
creo que es posible
interaccionar y relacionarnos con los
niños que forman parte de nuestras vidas
desde allí
habilitando una pedagogía de la
incomodidad que dé lugar a sus voces y a
sus miradas que les incluya genuinamente
y que nos permita construir un mundo
mejor no sólo para ellos sino
y sobre todo con ellos
[Música]